aujourd'hui j'ai parlé à un conseiller
de l'équipe de Vladimir Zelinski qui lui
avait été en contact avec des soldats
qui disaient que les Ukrainiens tiennent
encore backmouth et même si
effectivement ils ont perdu un petit peu
de terrain dans le centre-ville ont tout
de même le sentiment que la situation
s'est stabilisée par rapport à ce que
elle était il y a un mois par exemple
avant tout parce que la route par
laquelle les Ukrainiens accèdent à Bac
mout est devenu un petit peu moins
dangereux qu'elle l'était avant du fait
de certains gains de position je suppose
de l'armée ukrainienne tout est bien sûr
relatif cette route reste très
dangereuse mais les Ukrainiens ne sont
pas sur le point de perdre l'accès au
centre-ville après pour ce qui se passe
vraiment dans le centre-ville toujours
par la même source on me dit on me fait
parvenir les informations comme quoi il
ne convient même pas de parler de
bataille pour le contrôle de tel ou tel
route un coin de rue ou bâtiment il
s'agit de batailles pour telle ou tel
étage dans ce qui reste des bâtiments
des immeubles d'appartements surtout
dans le centre de Batman il se peut que
les Ukrainiens contrôlent un étage et
les Russes à notre étage ou que les
Ukrainiens sont en sous-sol et les
Russes au-dessus par exemple et puis
pour ce qui est la mairie j'ai vu une
vidéo filmée par un drone je pense que
cette vidéo est vrai d'après ce que je
vois mes souvenirs de batmouth pour y
avoir été avant la guerre la mairie
n'existe plus en fait ils ont planté un
drapeau sur les décombres